uh so this is my bedroom
i just got it redecorated for my 16th
birthday
it kind of started around about the
beginning of march and when i had a call
from school
and one of the favorite parts of it is
probably my wardrobe so i've got all the
memories
things like me and my friends things i'm
interested in
i've got so all of a sudden lila just
suddenly stopped eating
um do you know she was clearly counting
calories and then a majority of the
photos in there
sort of come from a polaroid camera it
seemed to spiral really quite quickly
um and it was it was it was horrific it
was frightening
lila has struggled with her mental
health for a decade
but during the pandemic it's got worse
and now she regularly harms herself
self-harm served as a real sort of a
release to me
i would um see if i had a bad day at
school or just a tough time
if i was going through something i just
felt very overwhelmed i definitely
did did get addicted to self-harm i look
back on it now
i definitely do regret it from being
referred for help to receiving treatment
took four months and all the while lyla
was getting worse
you can see things kind of progressively
kind of spiraling
um so yeah and you were almost that
crisis point by the time you kind of got
that initial
initial part appointment in well it's
lovely to see you
hi how are you doing lyla's eating
disorder self-harm and suicidal thoughts
have put her in serious risk she's
getting support
from children and adolescent mental
health services
or cams for short it was just like
trying to replace the thoughts
but it wasn't effective this is a busy
part of the nhs
and as children tried to cope with the
impact of the pandemic
it's getting busier so over the past
couple of months she's had a lot of life
stresses so
can you give me a phone call back please
there is one case more pressing than
probably any of the others
this cams team at pennine care nhs trust
is rated as excellent by the care
quality commission
but like many others it's understaffed
nationally
just one percent of all nhs funding goes
to cams
so it was just to let you know that
we've come to an outcome of that
and that it is that you've got the
diagnosis of autism
i was going to explain it a little bit
to you charlotte's a mental health nurse
and she's busy they're a member of staff
down here and that means more patients
have to wait to be seen
it makes you feel that you can do your
job
properly you can't do the job how you
set out at the beginning to do it
it feels like a big barrier you've got
children coming in who
they want to kill themselves you've got
children coming in who are self-harming
so that's stressful on its own but then
to add into the mix staffing issues
lack of resources and it feels
like overwhelming it feels overwhelming
thousands of children are waiting longer
than they should
because cams is under pressure in 2020
nearly 31 000 children were referred to
cams
38 percent of those children had to wait
more than the 18-week nhs target to get
their first assessment
and 34 of those who were accepted
had to wait more than 18 weeks to start
treatment
617 had to wait more than a year for
treatment
when you're at crisis point it is there
and everything kicks in
but you shouldn't have to get to crisis
point to be able to receive that service
yeah it's such like a an unimaginable
concept that
in order to get better and recover you
have to hit the bottom when you have to
get worse
the government says it wants to invest
79 million pounds into mental health
services for children and young people
but the royal college of psychiatrists
say that figure should be closer to
500 million pounds so for the people who
are in crisis and who absolutely need us
right now
there is not a weight but for the people
who have less of a crisis presentation
their weight is long and it's absolutely
heartbreaking
to to know that
even with the weight lila is one of the
lucky ones
she's now being seen but for too many
families
the path to treatment is a long one nick
martin sky news
you